kanye west shocking revelations the
moments he says led to his nervous
breakdown plus justin timberlake
seemingly admits well he hooked up with
the spice girl everyone this is the
daily denne denne and this this is kanye
west
we know Kanye loves to speak his mind
and ever since he popped back up on her
Twitter feeds it's like a third of the
internet wants to shut him up another
third is praising him and that last
third either doesn't care or they're
super confused by his latest rants well
buckle up because today Kanye appeared
on TMZ live and revealed he got addicted
to opioid medication he was taking after
liposuction he went on to say he got
hooked on the drugs during the st. Pablo
tour and this all led up to his
breakdown in November 2016 which kept
him in the hospital for over a week and
forced him to cancel the rest of the
tour I was drugged out I was on opioids
two days after I got off of opioids and
I was addicted to opioids two days I got
off of opioids um I'm in the hospital
now in another wild interview he sheds
more light on that nervous breakdown and
even takes on Taylor Swift again and
Beyonce in a nearly two-hour long
interview Kanye tells Charlamagne tha
God from the iHeartRadio is the
Breakfast Club that he thinks fear
stress being in control and manipulation
all led to his hospitalization part of
that stress he says was his wife Kim
Kardashian's Paris robbery competition
and the fact that the tracks off his
life of Pablo album weren't getting a
lot of radio play they put that same
amount if not more work into a piece of
work and then you used to it coming out
by graduation where everything is
everywhere you know it's frustrating and
really ever since the Taylor Swift
moment it just had never had never been
the same the connection with radio it's
like whatever powers that be it was much
harder after that Kanye blames the drama
over his song famous for not getting on
the radio as much and apparently that
was just one of the many factors that
led to the breakdown which he referred
to as a
break through for now the rapper says
he's in a stronger place but Taylor
isn't the only relationship he gets
candid about and the interview Kanye
talks about his falling-out with jay-z
he even calls out Jay and Beyonce for
not making it to his wedding to Kim
Kardashian in 2014 you know I gotta say
you know I was hurt about I was heard
about them not coming to the wedding
I understand they was going through some
things but if his family you know you're
not gonna miss a wedding you know and
I'm not I'm not using this interview to
put any negative things but I got a
statement breath yeah I got a steak my
truth and the truth shall set you free
Jesus
so where do things stand between Kanye
and jay-z now well yay says that they
are good and texting each other but how
about you to take this off the threat
and hang out in person you know spend
some quality time with each other in
fact you know Charlamagne actually ask
them about a possible one-on-one with
Jay and Kanye says it'll happen so what
do you guys think is Kanye being a
little too sensitive about jay-z and
Beyonce missing the wedding or should
they have shown up let me know in a
comment section now if you thought that
was some good teeth fresh off getting
their star on the Hollywood Walk of Fame
in sync stop by Ellen where she put them
through the ringer for a little game of
never have I ever and a very big secret
was revealed never have I ever hooked up
with the spice quizzes every never know
which one I saw girl let's go
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh did you catch that even I started
googling Justin's dating history after
that one
so which spice girl did JT bring sexy
back with Timberlake of course kept that
bit of info to himself but here's what
supposedly happened with some
photographic evidence in see first met
the Spice Girls in 1996 and Justin's
hookup with Baby Spice Emma Bunton
apparently happened in 2003 just before
his tour in the UK and wouldn't you know
it there she is sporting a JT concert
t-shirt
four months later Baby Spice was put on
the spot about their time together on
the Jonathan Ross show back in 2004
check it out
you had a thing with Justin Timberlake
didn't you you had a one-liner with him
is that way submitted for your
consideration number one I'm partied a
bit and he was very sweet he spoke about
this first cuz otherwise I would not say
no one is saying you're speaking out of
turn
does he call leader to do does he do
what we call the aftercare thumbs up
after said there's no way I'm pleased
here okay okay let's not forget Justin
is of course now happily married to
Jessica Biel and they have their son
stylist but Oh Ellen thanks for
uncovering this gem from the early 2000s
clearly Justin had a thing for blonde
singer's huh
back then well we have more with the
guys tonight on ET and over at et
online.com like and share this video
with your friends because there's a lot
to discuss your guys and I'll see you
tomorrow good bye
[Music]